i mean i i think you know there's been a
big movement especially with trump for
make made in america
and not just trump too because aoc
mentioned her shirts are made in america
as well which brings back to the tpp
oh yeah and the multinational
corporation takeover of the world which
leads in perfectly to our next article
well you want to talk right behind there
yes yes i've been done
all right are you gonna say mean things
about the pope me no no okay he might
there's a lot of mean things to say but
let's stay away from that and let's just
let's consider how low the bar is
exactly let's stay true to the
observations and to the evidence
provided
before us and then let the people decide
themselves what they want to think
that's been my kind
my understanding is that pope francis is
a pretty cool dude he chose the name
francis which was really exciting to me
i'm a fan
it's funny i'm a jew i'm not really a
practicing jew but i i've always
affiliated amongst catholics i don't
know i went to a catholic law school i
worked at a catholic hospital
and i love saint francis and i actually
have a saint francis in my house it took
me forever to find one without a cross
on saint francis hospital
did you i was in indianapolis i worked
at the saint francis hospital so
like i've always liked saint francis and
he is the first pope to pick that name
wow and i think that's really
interesting and it's very humbling
of name i don't know welcome he's just
uh he's just joined the great reset
movement
quartz reports pope francis is backing a
new movement to redefine capitalism as a
force for good
first of all i think depending on your
definition of capitalism
in the traditional sense it's been a
force for good i certainly think
there's there's an issue with major
corporations extracting value and
providing nothing in return
but i think uh you know capitalism the
system has left
as a system has lifted more people out
of poverty than anything else
i think it's interesting the way they're
framing it well let's read
court says capitalism has been condemned
for many of the world's evils
from massive income inequality to
climate change but self-interest wasn't
the core idea of the economic system
first codified by adam smith in 18th
century
avarice became coupled with capitalism
in the 1980s fueled largely by nobel
prize-winning economist milton
friedman's theory
that the singular goal of business is to
maximize profits for shareholders
in short it was the argument that greed
is good
now ago a new global alliance with pope
francis
as its moral leader is pushing to rescue
the heart of capitalism and reorient it
as a force for social good the founding
members of the coalition for inclusive
capitalism
with the vatican comprises large
corporations like the bank of like
like bank of america bp estee lauder ey
johnson
johnson
mastercard merck sales force and visa it
also includes grant giving bodies like
the ford foundation the rockefeller
foundation
government bodies and the international
trade union confederation
the world's largest workers rights
unions yes i'm sorry
the world's largest workers rights group
yes because
nothing says capitalism as a force for
good then massive multinational
unaccountable corporations that exploit
people for personal gains and big banks
and big pharma that are part of this
coalition which is being
all organized by lynn forrester the
rochchild
that's bringing this coalition together
to redefine
capitalism as of course all these same
institutional powers are talking about
a global reset and redefining capitalism
and again we have to understand these
individuals these corporations they
don't operate under the capitalistic
system
they operate under the socialistic
system since they get government
handouts and welfare more than anyone
else
imaginable and they are the ones that
are partly responsible for all the pain
and suffering
that is being caused so believing that
these individuals are going to fix the
problem that they were causing
is absolutely no no no no no no no no no
left are you are you
i i told you i identify with ron swanson
more than anyone else do you know who
ron swanson is isn't that from a show
isn't it yes
rex the guy who doesn't like government
right and i do need to acknowledge
that that we have to look at everything
fairly and honestly and when we look at
these individuals grandstanding
talking about capitalism is bad we have
to understand we're not operating under
capitalism we're und
we're operating under socialism for the
super rich
and then quasi crony capitalism that
doesn't even exist because of that
for everyone else we look at this
largest transfer of wealth we look at
all the pain and suffering it's all
under the fingerprints of this
quasi-fake system that manipulates
lies to us and takes advantage of us in
so many different ways it's socialism
for me
and capitalism for thee that's not even
not even like you i don't really
sound left yes i know i i do like that's
like you know but really but the but the
the modern left is pro
corporate i should say no with respect
to you and what yeah your view was left
the democratic establishment is
extremely pro-corporate yes
and there are a lot of what we would
what what is koloko described as left
like uh personalities who are in line
with the democratic party and joe biden
and i and i am here to tell you they're
not really left
they would absolutely say they're left
just like a member of congress can pay
to be in the progressive caucus
that doesn't make it so i could pay you
to be in the black caucus you know
it doesn't make me black this is this is
this is hilarious that some of the worst
offenders in terms of exploitation and
manipulation are claiming they're going
to make
capitalism a force for good when they're
the ones who actually ruined it
yeah when when capitalism was at its
root free trade between individuals is
great
when capitalism became large
corporations that extract value from the
working class and give very little in
return that became the problem
and i'm not talking about for everyone
who's listening ceos who are high paid
and maybe managing companies
i'm talking about people who just sit
like in miami in a skyscraper
and just check their bank because they
get profits from the company they're not
adding they're not managing anything
so there's there's there's serious
challenges this is where like my left
comes out in
the difference between the modern
structure of this corporate
i guess you call it corporatist is it
it's it's protective yeah it's
corporatism
where they have such control over the
system
with lobbying that smaller businesses
can't compete
they can they can crush you starbucks
can open two starbucks locations next to
your small business
and just wipe you out yeah and then that
prevents
any real competition any real free
market there's you don't get it
if you have massive corporations
strangling everybody that's why i've
always been in favor of a mixed economy
they pay a lot of money for that right
the the head of starbucks pays a lot of
money to be able to do what they do
yeah before we get into that if you keep
reading the article these people
talk to you like your little children
because what you
see them exemplify is just simple
language like we're going to help the
poor
everyone's going to be equal we're going
to support black and african american
businesses and we're going to fight
a global warming and if you look at
these individuals a lot of them are
directly responsible
for causing the problems that they
allegedly want more power
more responsibility for them to fix yeah
like joe biden yeah it's absolutely
crazy
to rubber-stamp this and join this
global coalition of good guys and
superheroes is absolutely just
mind-boggling and should be worrying to
a lot of people out there when youtube
announced
that they will censor people who
challenge you know the election and say
there's fraud
will chamberlain we had him on the show
he tweeted tell me why national
why uh why what he he basically said
i'll paraphrase because i don't
have the exact quote that nationalizing
these big tech companies
is better than letting him just do what
they do
and manipulate everything well i i have
no problem with that you know
these and especially when you were
talking about the communications um
companies and that would help a lot with
what we were talking about in terms of
you know your first amendment rights
well this is the frustrating part here
because a lot of these big monopolies
wouldn't be
where they are without government
without public assistance yes
without tax cuts without working with
the dod the pentagon especially when you
look at institutions like
google when you look at the startup
foundations that are connected to the
cia
that have their direct fingerprints on
all the big tech monopolies that are in
power now
and when you look at amazon google and
all these other monoliths
they are working one-on-one with
government right now whether it's amazon
giving all the chairs and and uh all the
little pens for
the pentagon or the military or google
yeah i mean
amazon if this is a jeff bezos problem
this goes to that i mean
he's getting ready to just own our water
sources and just basically oh did you
see that news where like water is going
to be added as a commodity there's going
to be water
talking about soon and not many people
are really scary he's threatening
i i find him to be very threatening i
mean and also symbolic of the greater
threat isn't it isn't it easier just to
say that the real battle
is like uh establishment versus
anti-establishment
or liberty versus authority we call it
corporate versus non-corporate and
really it's just like
but government plays a role in this too
well it is but your government
representative
is either on the payroll or not on the
payroll so when you look at it in a in
the micro level like who
who is your person representing if
they're taking corporate money they're
representing corporations
i think you know in a simple definition
corporations are a good thing and i
think in a simple definition government
is a good thing
but what we have are giant authoritarian
monopolistic
government and corporations we need
publicly financed elections we
there there is there are certain things
that it's hard though it's really
difficult to get
you know well you would have to get
enough people in there that aren't on
the corporate payroll that would then
support that
so it's we're chipping away at it
basically is what we're trying to do but
you get enough people in there that
aren't corporate they'd be willing to do
that
so i mean that's the goal i just say put
them in nascar suits and let them
represent all the corporations that they
represent
absolutely same with doctors doctors as
well need to point out the corporations
that they get money from so people know
who they're doing
we're not even allowed to say it in a
lot of cases when you start bringing up
stuff like where they get their money
from
you're smearing them you're you know
you're not being part of the team
especially if it's a democrat calling
out another democrats corporate donors
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for
free if you want to listen to us there
thanks for hanging out and we will see
you all
next time